THEIR GRASP AT THE TOP OF THE
PACIFIC DIVI
OFF TRAFFIC IN FRONT.
UT THE OTH
SIDE.
HIT IN THE
LARSSON WAS THERE.
HE WENTG PUCKS OVER.
LIND DOWN THE WING.UALITY CHANC.
ADAM LARSSON LOOKING FOR
THEY SCORE.
FIRED HOME BY RYAN DONATO AND
THE FIRST GREAT LOOK.
HE WASN'T LOOKING AT
AND IT'S A 1-1  MATTHEW  CARLIS
BROTHER HAYDEN A MEMBER OF THE
KRAKEN INJURED RIGHT
RASK.
SCORES!
VICTOR RASK ABLE TO FIRE IT HOM.
BUMPED BY HANIFIN.
IN FRONT TO EBERLECORNER.
CUTS IN  IN AND
THE BIG DEFENCEMAN MAKES IT 3-1
SEATTLE LATE SECOND PERI BAD LI
BYDRIEDGER.
WORKING IN ON KRAKEN ON THE
PLAY.
>> Kelly: MIKAEL BACKLUND AND
LINDHOLM WORK WELL ON THIS ONE.
HERE'S THAT GREAT POINT NUMBER
100 FOR JOHNNY GAUDREAU 100TH P
JOHNNY GAUDREAU IN THIS SEASON.
FIRST TIME EVER FOR T NOW.
A PASS IN FRONT.
ROWN BACK IN ALONE IN
FRONT.
AND THIS IS WHAT GOOD TEAMS DO..
EBERLE  BY THE
KRAKEN TO DEFEND.
HOW ABOUT JORDAN EBERLEHANIFIN.
AND THE FLAMES UP AND RIMS IT F.
STOPPED BY VLADAR.
SCORES!
HAT TRICKNIERS.
THAT ALLOWS JOHNNY GAUDREAU TO
GET THE PUCK TO